CHRIS KLEBAN: Hi, and
welcome to today's session
where we'll be talking about
the new accelerator optimize VM
family, targeting machine
learning and HPC workloads.
My name's Chris Kleban, and I'm
the product manager of GPUs,
and I'm going to start talking
about what my goal is, why
I show up to work, and it
really comes down to helping you
with your application.
Some customers pick
infrastructure service
to run their fleet, some
paths or platforms of service,
or managed service offerings.
No matter what you
pick, the key to success
is the right infrastructure,
performance, total cost
of ownership, reliability,
security, so on and so forth.
So to that end, we want to make
sure the best GPU compute is
enabled on Google Cloud.
Not only that, we
want to make it
easy to get started,
easy to scale,
and easy to optimize
performance.
But it's not just
the infrastructure,
it's all about your workload.
It's about machine
learning or rendering,
or CUDA compute, or
HPC, or visualization.
You want to make sure we
have the right products that
fit your needs.
So let's talk a
little bit about that.
We're going to talk about how
committed we are to that goal.
Last year we were
very proud to announce
that we were the first major
cloud to offer the T4 GPU.
This is a very
low-cost compute option
with great performance
for inference,
visualization for a lot
of scale-out computing.
Every day, I'm staggered by the
growth of this product line.
There's one customer who's done
autonomous vehicle customer,
and they do
large-scale simulations
to ensure that self-driving
cars are safe on the road using
the T4 GPUs.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
let's talk about the
best performance.
Historically, we've had the K80
and P100 and V100, new products
all the time.
And continuing on
that, last month
I'm super proud to announce
that we're the first cloud
to offer the A100 GPU.
You can come and get it
today, sign up for the alpha
and get access right away.
Not only that, I'm proud
to say that we got up
to 16 of these GPUs
in a single VM,
and we'll talk a little
bit about that later.
As you can see on the right
the picture, these HGX boards
and A100's from NVIDIA,
there's eight of them
on board, the special NV link,
and it takes special server
hardware to house them.
So Google Compute Engine.
Infrastructure to
the Service on GCP.
Historically, we've
been a one family
shop, one product, the N one.
It was great because it
served all workloads.
You can customize it to
your needs, the right CPU,
the right memory, the
right storage, optional
in server SSD, network
attached storage,
then you can add GPUs as
you want, what type of GPU,
how many GPUs.
Very customizable.
Then you continue that
family with the N2,
the N2D for Intel an
AMD's CPU processing.
But we went left and we
went right, went low cost,
cost to optimize E2 VMs for
customers looking for the best
TCO for CPU-based
compute, but then we
add a suite of new VM families
targeting specific workloads.
This is where we looked at
the workload, and we said,
what does this need to succeed?
We built special hardware,
special virtualization
configuration, and that's
what today's new accelerator
optimized A2 VM family is about.
Let's talk a little
bit more about that.
Before talking about
our family, let's talk
about the key
component of the A2
VM, which is the new NVIDIA A100
GPU that they just announced.
This is a generational
leap of performance
over the current V100,
up to 20x speeds,
floating 0.64 precision,
over 2x speed improvement.
This is used for scientific
computing and HPC workloads
that you really
need high accuracy.
FP32, kind of the de facto
ML training out of the box.
You turn it on, make it go
without any optimizations.
Here the A100's MPR
technology, the new TF32 really
shines out the 10x speed
improvements or 20x speed
attunements when you use
NVIDIA's optional sparsity
feature.
FP16, again, to 5% increase in
performance roughly, and N to 8
precision 10 or 20x.
Great for ML inference batch.
So a lot of performance.
It's going to be just a very
minor price increase on V100,
so it's going to have the
best TCO for GPU power compute
workloads.
A little more on the
TF32 tensor cores.
We're getting far into how the
data is processed and stored
here, but really, there's two
key things I want to point out.
TF32 versus FP32,
today, a lot of code
that just points to FP32 out of
the gate, switch over to TF32.
And NVIDIA spent a lot
of time to make sure
that per lap
processing, less data,
you get much more performance.
And for a lot of
workload, it doesn't
matter because the
ML model's prediction
how accurate the model actually
is at detecting a person
or doing a translation
is really impacted by it,
and you get better performance.
Also new on A100's, the
support for bfloat16.
So four different
models for ML training
that you could use here,
and it's very flexible.
Pick the one that meets
your workfload needs.
I'd like to talk about a
new feature on the A100,
the multi-instance GPU.
I'm really excited at
this for two reasons.
First, it allows multiple
applications at the same time
to be on a single GPU.
You can create two
partitions, anywhere up
to seven partitions.
Not only does it
allow you to create
a run, multiple applications
on a single GPU,
it creates fault
isolation, performance
guarantees so that
you don't have
to worry about one app
running into another.
Additionally, a very
common enterprise
focused buying mechanism is
to commit to long-term usage,
like a three-year committed
usage discount on these new A2
VMs that we're
about to talk about,
but there's some risk to that.
The risk is we've
already told you
we're going to launch the
best GPU hardware there is,
so what if we launch
a new hardware
before your commitment is up?
This multi-instance
GPU feature, in a way,
it future proofs
your investment.
You might run a single workload
for ML training on full GPUs,
on one GPU, 8, 16,
whatever for years.
But maybe your business changes.
Maybe you want to run
inference because you've
done the research on
the training already.
So you switched to these
multi-instance GPUs
and you run different workloads.
So it's dynamic,
it's future proof,
and it also increases
overall efficiency
of your infrastructure.
Now, I am not a data
scientist, so I'm just
going to give you a
high-level overview, sparsity,
but it turns out you don't need
to process every single data
point in every single
calculation in an AI neural
network.
So as the graph shows,
just doesn't do it.
But by just not
doing some, again,
doesn't impact
accuracy of the models.
You can get a 2x
speed improvement.
The video is going to
include some software
and some features to make
this easier to implement,
and you can judge for yourself
whether or not to turn this on
based on your need of accuracy.
So all together, a lot of
improvement in A100 GPU.
So let's pivot and talk
about our A2 VM family.
So again, we started
with the ML workload.
We started with HPC.
We figured out
what does it need.
So the first thing that got
us excited about the A100 GPU
was the 40 gigabits of memory.
This is really needed
because of ML modeling
getting more innovative,
which means more data.
Same thing with HPC or
GPU-powered databases.
It's about data
is getting bigger,
and you need to store more
of it and process more of it.
This is the largest GPU
memory in this family of V100
and P100 models to date.
We offer 16 of these
GPUs in a single VM,
which means you can get a
staggering 640 gigs in GPU
memory in a single host.
On top of that, we taped two
Cascade Lake CPUs from Intel
with 96 vCPUs and up to
1.3 terabytes of memory.
This is really important
because two reasons.
One, some customers come to us
whether it be financial or ML
or science and saying, I just
have too big of a data set.
My GPU power I need
might be variable,
but I need to have the
VM for big memory size.
So one, the memory size is
much larger than past products.
Two, we have a 2x ratio,
640 of GPU memory and 2x
of that on VM memory.
And that's because we want
to allow for pre-processing
of data, pumping
it into the GPU,
and high performance
for the actual workload.
Google is known
to be an AI expert
and we worked very
closely with those people
to ensure optimum performance
for this configuration.
We didn't stop there.
We took NVIDIA's
NVLink 3 technology
and made GPU-to-CPU
communication ultra fast,
and we'll talk a
little bit more about.
We continue optionality
in the sense of we
allow you to use
network attached storage
or bring in server or local SSD
storage for faster disk I/O.
For virtualization,
we spent a lot of time
saying, how do we get you
consistent performance?
How do we optimize
performance, and how do we
make it transparent in the way
that your application could
take best use of
this infrastructure?
So we made a lot of
improvements on vNUMA and NUMA
scheduling to get those
characteristics for you.
For scale-out workflows,
we spent a lot of time
on the network stack.
You'll see the A2 family comes
with two flavors, the high GPU
flavor, and the mega GPU flavor.
The high GPU flavor goes
up to 8 GPUs, and 96 vCPUs.
That's great if you
have a little bit
more pre-processing power
for image recognition
or other type of workloads
with 12 CPUs for 1 GPU.
It also comes with 100 gigabits
of network performance.
So if you want to scale
out more linearly,
the high GPU is a
nice flavor to have.
But for the customers who
want the ultimate GPU parallel
performance, we
have A2 mega GPU--
16 GPUs, 100 gigabit networking,
local SSD, high vRAM.
On both of these two flavors
for scale-out workload,
we spent a lot of
time optimizing
NVIDIA nickel library.
If you just take
the open source,
out-of-the-box library that
enables VM-to-VM communication
versus what we have, our
optimized version of that that
we make available to you-- and
it's something we'll explain
later--
there's a 70% up to
70% speed improvement
for these network tests.
And when you're
scaling your workload
to one VM, two VMs, 10 VMs,
100 VMs and so on and so forth,
that's really important.
Let's look a little deeper on
this A2 mega GPU VM instance.
So NVIDIA has delivered
these HG exports.
There's eight GPUs
A100s per board,
and there's a
high-speed NVLink fabric
allowing for GPU-to-GPU
communication on a single HGX.
But we've worked
closely with NVIDIA
to provide a server
platform that
combines two HGX boards
with a very tightly
inter-coupled NVLink fabric.
So now you have 16 GPUs
with all-to-all NVLink
connectivity with 9.6 terabytes
per second of peak bandwidth.
Why that's important is it
allows you a couple of things.
One, it allows you to use
the 640 g of GPU memory
as a unified memory
fabric through support
of the CUDA tool sets.
Also, what it does, it
enables you to really linearly
your scale performance.
It's the ultimate
scale-up box because
of the GPU-to-GPU continuity.
In terms of scale out, again,
I talked about the network
performance where
you can have multiple
of these systems
running together
that makes [INAUDIBLE]
training go very fast
or any type of ML
model training.
It also works very well
for a lot of HPC workloads.
In terms of performance
of one of these VMs,
for FP16, 10
petaFLOPS to reform it
in a single VM or 20
petaFLOPS for inference.
These terms, these numbers
maybe are meaningless,
maybe they mean something
to you, but what they mean
is model performance
really good TCO.
For the same amount
of budget, you
can get a lot more
work done, which
means a lot more
innovation or enabling
you to focus on the things
that matter for your business.
In terms of applications,
NVIDIA spent
a lot of time working on how
do I enable more and more CUDA
compute?
In our GCP marketplace or
via NVIDIA's GPU cloud,
there's prepackaged
containers with tons
of applications that are ready
to go that have GPU power.
You don't need to worry
about installing the drivers
or the applications.
Just get the container,
run it on Google Cloud,
run it on the A2
or any of our GPUs.
For AI workloads, we've
been talking a lot
about that bottom stack on this
picture, the infrastructure
layer.
We're committed to
providing the best
infrastructure no matter
what, no matter what
your choice of hardware is.
Up above the stack,
if you don't want
to worry about the
infrastructure on GCE
or in Kubernetes engine,
all support the new A2 VM,
we have the AI platform.
This is a managed
service offering
that allows you
to do ML training
as a service, predictions
as the service,
get quickly started
with Notebooks.
You don't have to
manage capacity pools
or worry about
anything like that.
Just have your
data scientists use
the tools that's best for
them powered by these new VMs
I've been talking about.
Going up the stack in the layer
one more time, hit Auto ML.
This is where you can create
custom models for your business
based on your data, but you
don't have to know PyTorch.
You don't need to
know TensorFlow.
You just bring your data,
let us do the work for you.
Or if a bunch of APIs that
developers could just quickly
access the development
language of their choice using
a series of pre-trained
models, things
like vision or translation,
get started super quickly.
All of this is powered, again,
by world class infrastructure,
including these A2 VMs.
Let's talk a little bit more
about performance improvements
for real workloads.
I talked before
about just how many
operations a second
can the thing do,
but really what matters
is the workload.
So for ML training, one of
the most data demanding,
GPU-demanding applications
is the bird language model,
teaching a computer how
to understand language,
how to have conversations.
It's a very popular
one right now.
And you can see a 3x
or a 6x improvement
over the V100
previous generation.
Are own internal tests have
seen workloads that have taken
about a week, take about a day.
Our customers that are
alpha reporting using FP16,
real-world scenarios very
close to that 3x improvement.
I believe I saw it was
a 2.8 last I checked.
So these numbers
provided by NVIDIA, we
are seeing real similar
things from our customers.
On inference, again, A100,
big step forward over V100.
T4 is still the great
product, but sometimes you
want a little bit more
bandwidth on inference.
For batch workload, you can use
seven of those GPU partitions
to get a really large amount
of inference workload.
For some workloads,
it's not just inference.
Perhaps it's
reinforcement learning
that's using a model to do game
simulations at the same time
training the model as well.
So both of these are
really important for
these large-scale workloads.
So hopefully, it
should be very clear
why and how the A2
VM on GCE is going
to be highest performance.
And while we haven't announced
public pricing it, trust me,
it's going to be the
best TCO on Google Cloud.
Let's talk a little bit about
GPU-accelerated Apache Spark.
Now, what Spark is,
it's a framework,
it's a tool set where a lot
of data scientists, analysts
use the software.
In the old world, Spark 2.0,
it would be a CPU cluster.
You'd pipe a bunch of data in,
you would process that data,
format it, maybe even
remove PII information.
You put it in storage,
then you would
have to have another cluster
of configuration hardware
that would do an ML model
training or an HPC job or run
analysis.
So NVIDIA and Google
worked together
to help speed up
that by bringing
GPU power to both model training
as well as data preparation.
Spark 3.0 supports both
of this through rapids,
and now Google's
Managed Service Dataproc
supports Spark 3 0
clusters and all six
of our GPU product offerings
from an infrastructure
perspective.
I'm really looking forward
to seeing how customers
can use these really
large A100 VMs for data
preparation and model training.
So we've talked
a lot about A100.
We've talked about
AI and HPC workloads,
talked about the performance.
It's the newest thing.
It's very high demand.
It's alpha is available today.
There's a sign-up form.
Please sign up.
But it's not just the
only thing we have.
We have five other GPUs all
doing a wide range of services,
whether it be ML training
or inference, rendering,
computation,
visualization, we'll
have a product to
meet your needs.
Well, we have all
of these, and you're
happy and welcome
to use any of them.
I wanted talk about
the T4 a little bit.
Now since the launch,
what we've noticed
is there's a very high
demand for a VM with maybe
a variable amount of CPU in
memory and some GPU compute
power.
And I think because
of that, you're
seeing a lot of
growth, more growth
than you would expect,
both in the inference use
case, social media
companies, self-driving car
simulations, the hatch
workloads, real-time streaming
workloads.
Then I want to talk a little
bit more about inference
for a second.
So GCP thinks the T4, plus our
spread region availability,
plus our network offers a great
global low-latency inference
product.
Low-latency inference
is really important
because a lot of
user experiences
have predictions and
AI built into that,
whether you're on a mobile app
and you're interacting with AR
and seeing pictures, or
if you are getting ads,
and you want those
ads specifically
recommended to you, or
you're using sort of game
where the game has AI
intelligence built in,
if it's slow and
laggy, your users
aren't going to want that.
So the T4 has ultra low
latency for inference, just 1
millisecond.
You combine that with
our global availability
of the product spread
around the world,
we're going to have
capacity close to user-base
higher populations.
And the third major component
of this is our network.
I've come from a network
background myself,
and I'm very familiar
with how networks operate.
And there's two things
that really surprised me
about Google's network
and why it will help here.
One, just the sheer investment.
Fiber optic cables,
points of presence,
software-defined networking.
The network stack
was built at first
for ultra-low latency,
that's how do you
get Google search to your web
browser as fast as we can?
We've added a YouTube,
video streaming,
and a series of other services
for high bandwidth use cases.
That same network that's
optimized for that
is what powers Google Cloud.
And one feature specifically,
the Google Cloud default
internet networking
connectivity,
could be called cold potato
routing in the sense of we
don't want to get
rid of your traffic
and pump it on the internet
as quickly as possible,
regardless of packet
loss of issues.
We optimize how do we
do it, low latency,
how do we connect directly
with ISPs, and let's
hold it over our own fiber
and our own network as long
as possible to that end user.
So the combination
of those things
means global availability,
low latency on the GPUs,
a great network, so a very
high quality user experience
for real-time inference work.
Let's talk about
preemptible GPUs.
In essence, this is our spare
capacity and your cost savings.
There could be a lot of reasons
why we have spare capacity.
Maybe we're building ahead
of time before demand,
or maybe other users are
running batch workloads that
spin up thousands of
GPUs at one moment
and zero GPUs at the other.
But either way, there are
moments we have spare capacity.
So we make it easy to
find that with Kubernetes
Engine or a feature
I'll talk about next.
But what one
customer did is they
said, how do I use
Kubernetes preemptible GPUs,
and how do I do
more of the same?
So they were processing hundreds
of thousands of music files
and then went to processing
millions of music files, all
for the same budget.
It made it easy for them
through preemptible VMs,
and they saved 70% or 80%.
There is a downside,
which is you can't always
guarantee this
capacity will be here,
so you've got to have
flexible completion times.
In this case, it worked out.
There's a blog link on our blog.
Please go check it
out, and thank you
for the customer story.
I really appreciate that.
To that end, I talked about
not only having the best GPUs,
but making it easy
and easy to scale.
A previous example
was on Kubernetes,
but perhaps you use VM or GCE.
So for a long time, we've had
managed instance groups that
allow you to scale up and down
GPU capacity or any capacity,
but we have a new
feature that lets
you find spare GPU
capacity called
the distribution shape ANY.
So instead of worrying about
how much capacity we have where
and working with
our capacity team,
just create yourself
matters interest group,
set your targeted region,
set the target quantity
of capacity, and
allow us to find
those VMs' capacity for you.
This is specifically useful
in the preemptible case, where
you know you're only getting
access to our spare capacity,
and why not let us
find that for you.
So I'm excited to see
the usage of this so far.
Let's talk about
another exciting way
we make it easy to get started
and to get high performance,
the deep learning environment.
When I first started
as a product manager
a few years ago on GPUs, I do
what normal product managers
do, I tried the product
and listen to users.
And one of the
things way back then
I was surprised to
find how easy it
was to use the
infrastructure, create it,
but how hard it was
for the software.
So deep learning environments
meant to solve that.
They pre-configure the
drivers, the libraries.
They pre-configure
PyTorch or TensorFlow,
a series of applications,
and they package it
as VM images or containers.
Not only that, these put in
performance optimizations,
like the nickel library
we talked about before.
Easy to get started.
Easy to scale up.
Let's talk a little bit
about TensorFlow Enterprise.
For some customers who
perhaps, want enterprise grade
support or just those
cloud scale performance
optimizations, these
DL VMs, or containers
that we talked about
before, are there for you.
Not only that, the
team has worked hard
to get access to TF 1 and
TF 2, supporting the A100
available today that's not quite
available on the open source
TensorFlow.
So really excited to see that.
Our alpha customers are already
running on TensorFlow, 1 and 2
on our A2 VMs.
And to wrap up
today's talk, I just
want to show you how
simple it is to get
started with all the things.
Let's say I have a TensorFlow
2 code I want to run
or a Notebook, I spin
up a gcloud command,
pick the new A2 VM
family; size, 1 GPU.
I pick the prepackaged
VM container
that has everything I
needed, all the performance
optimization and software.
Hit Enter.
I get infrastructure.
I connect to the Jupyter
Notebook, and I get started.
I want to thank you
for listening to today
and learning about the
A2 VM family, new on GCE
with NVIDIA A100.
We are now in alpha.
I encourage you to sign up
and get started right away.
Our public availability
will be soon.
Thank you, and have a great day.